[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
investigating anti-microbial mechanisms
of action using automated genome-wide
and gene-specific editing i am marie
stone of lab roots and i'll be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by inscripta to learn more visit
inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
aaliyah clark alsyad senior research
associate at inscripta aliyah you may
now begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction
today for the webinar i'm going to be
talking about how we used the onyx
genome engineering platform
to study the mechanism of action of two
different small molecules
to do this we built genome-wide as well
as gene-specific libraries
we then used these libraries in
selection experiments with the addition
of the small molecules
and then after the selection experiments
we
analyzed the distribution of the
different edits within the library
and this allowed us to make hypotheses
about how we think these small molecules
are acting on the cell
both of the small molecules that we
studied in this work come from plants
originally
and so i'm going to start off by giving
some background on antimicrobials of
plant origin
i'm then going to talk about the onyx
platform and how we actually built the
genome libraries
i'm then going to talk about the work we
did to study the mechanism of action of
the first small molecule camaric acid
and then i'm going to talk about the
work we did to study
the second small molecule resveratrol
so antimicrobials
of plant origin they are typically used
by the plants as defense mechanisms
and tend to be secondary metabolites for
the plants
they have a relatively low toxicity
compared to synthetic antibiotics
and they have a lower incidence of drug
resistance than antimicrobials from
other
sources shown here are two plants that i
think we're all familiar with on the
left is elderberry
and that was found to have
antimicrobial
activity against clinically relevant
strains of bacteria
and then shown here on the right is dill
and that was shown to also have
antimicrobial activity activity against
bacteria due to the terpenoids that it
produces
so the antimicrobials of plant origin
for these reasons outlined here these
are
um very valuable
small molecules
and as a result there could be desire to
produce these small molecules
however there's oftentimes challenges
associated with the isolation of the
antimicrobials in the plants themselves
this is typically due to the fact that
they're produced in very small
amounts
and there's also challenges with the
isolation because it oftentimes requires
many different
chemical conversion steps which could
make the processes very difficult and
time consuming
and so as a result
it's possible to port the production
pathways over into microbes which would
allow for
more scale up in production
an example of this is artemisinin this
is used as a treatment for malaria
artemisinin is derived from the plant
artemisia annual
however shown here is an outline of this
production pathway in yeast
so here in the yeast the acetyl coa
through different enzymatic convergence
is eventually converted into artemisinic
acid
and then through chemical conversion is
converted into artemisinin
and this would be just one example
of how you could use microbes to
produce such a compound
however if you don't actually know how
the
antimicrobial is acting
on the microbe it could make
the production the bioproduction of the
small molecule
difficult
and so for the work that i'm going to be
talking about today
i'm going to talk about a way that you
could easily study the mechanism of
action of a small molecule
here i'm going to outline a
a summary of what we did to study the
mechanism of action of our two small
molecules
so shown here in a schematic is this
small molecule that
is acting on your cell in some way and
you don't know
what the
the mechanism is
so
with the onyx it allows you to design
many different types of genome libraries
here are three examples of the
genome-wide library of the genome
libraries which we used in this work
so
with the onyx you can make
genome-wide
targets such as all transcription
factors and you can make
different insertions or deletions
to these
genome-wide targets
you're also able to make precise edits
to essential genes such as rpoa
and you're also able to
target entire cellular pathways
and in the work that we did we built a
library that targeted
um specifically the cell division
pathway
as in addition to
an entire morphology and protein folding
library
so once you have your libraries designed
and built you're able to then use them
in selection experiments
so you would grow your cell library
with the addition of your small molecule
and then after
you complete your selection experiment
with the onyx all of the designs are
trackable and so you're able to look at
the distribution
of the designs within the library
and so when you do that it would be
possible that you would see certain
mutations
which
enrich
upon the addition of your small molecule
or certain mutations which deplete in
the population
i'm next going to walk through the
entire onyx platform
um from start to finish for um building
the libraries as well as doing a
selection experiment
and how you would actually go about
doing this so with the encrypted
designer software this makes it very
easy to
design all of your genome libraries and
you can make between 100 to 10 000
different designs per library
and this would be the design
phase of the platform
next would be the generate
phase and this is where you're actually
building your libraries
so shown here is the onyx instrument and
here are all of your consumables
and this makes it very easy to just load
your consumables
into the
instrument and push a button and then
the instrument will run
and you'll then end up with a pool of
cells which contain
your library of designs
next would be the test phase
so
you would be able to perform a selection
experiment or
a screening experiment
and then with the genotyping kits and
the analysis software you would be able
to look at which designs
are
actually present in your cell
and then with the learn phase
you would use the inscriptor resolver
software to
enter in all of your results from the
genotyping kits and computationally
assess your cell library composition
here i'm going to walk through the e
coli onyx selection workflow and
this was what we used for our work this
was done in e coli so
i'm going to outline that so you will
start with your e coli input cells
these will then be loaded onto the onyx
instrument for an edit competency run
and this will then allow your cells to
be editable with the onyx technology
once you have your cells that went
through the edit
competency run
they are then able to go through the
onyx genome engineering run where you
would input the
dna the design dna that is specific for
your library
and then
after this run you will end up with your
pool of cells which
will be
edited after you have this pool
these cells are then able to go through
a selection experiment
after the selection you will then
extract the genomic dna from your cells
and then they will be
sent for ngs sequencing and then
that data will be analyzed and this is
what will allow you to make the
association between the phenotype and
the genotype
the onyx chemistry is what really
enables the
the scale of having this many edits
in your population and then also to have
the trackability of all of your
different designs
shown here on the left is the onyx
chemistry so you have the guide rna
the donor dna as well as the barcode all
connected as one piece
and this barcode allows for the
trackability
and we define trackability as the
ability to identify the reagents
associated with a cell in a complex cell
library
with our barcode diversity assay
this is what
allows you to actually figure out the
represent the design distribution of
your
cell population
and so when you have your
culture here you'll extract the genomic
dna
and then using that dna the
barcodes will be pcr'd
and then these amplicons will then be
sent for sequencing
so shown here are the two
small molecules which we used in this
work
on the left is camaric acid
camaric acid is a cinnamic acid and then
here on the right is resveratrol which
is a stevenoid
kumaric acid is has
numerous
beneficial properties so
it is antioxidant it has anti-tumor
properties as well as anti-inflammatory
properties
it's found in multiple
common day foods including
cauliflower
onions as well as radishes
resveratrol also has different
beneficial properties it is
cardioprotective
anti-inflammatory
and it is derived from camaric acid
um and it's found in grapes shown here
is a wine press and then
um also passion fruit
we chose these compounds for
our selection experiments
um because they really represent two
different use cases for the onyx for
studying
the mechanism of action of
antimicrobials
so
cumeric acid um we had prior data
suggesting that
it was
affecting a specific cell target rpoa
and so based on that we were able to
start off by making a more specific
library to that due to prior data
and then resveratrol there
when we started looking at this and in
the literature there were multiple
um different hypotheses of how
resveratrol could be acting however we
didn't really have any
definitive data suggesting
the mechanism of action so we really
didn't have a lead
target to go off of
and then also because resveratrol is
derived from kumeric acid
they serve as very good controls during
the experiment for one another
so for the selections that we did with
turmeric acid
what we saw
after looking at the data from our
libraries was that it really showed in
rpoa that there were
enriching a pocket of enriching
mutations and then a pocket of depleting
mutations
and these really clustered
nicely onto the structure of rpoa such
that there were a lot of enriching
mutations in the n-terminal domain and
then a lot of depleting mutations in the
c-terminal domain
so
previous work at inscripto was done in
collaboration with marcus aeroguard's
lab at dtu
such that a an initial
genome-wide library was built and this
had 992 barcoded strains
it had 373 adaptive
laboratory evolution variants which were
identified
in marcus aeroguard's lab
it also had
168 insertions of mobile elements
as well as 442 knockouts and n-terminal
frame deletions
once this pool of barcoded strains was
built
it was grown in biological triplicate
and then grown
in m9 with glucose
and
with the addition of
7.5 makes per ml camaric acid
after these selection after these
cultures were allowed to grow for the
duration of the selection
the genomic dna was extracted and the
pcr
and the barcodes were pcr'd and these
amplicons
were sent for sequencing
here on the left we're looking at a
graph that it's outlining
the enrichment of the different designs
and then here on the right we're looking
at a structure
of rna polymerase with the alpha subunit
shown in orange here
so shown here on the left in this graph
is
the log twofold change of the designs in
the cumuric acid over the
m9 abundance and so anything here on the
right would be enriching in the
population
and anything shown here on the left
would be depleting in the population
and so that these ones that were
enriching we would say that these are
more tolerant to the cumeric acid
whereas the depleting mutations would be
less tolerant
and when we
actually look at all of these different
designs they are all in rpoa
and when they are mapped onto the
structure of rpoa
the enriching variants map very nicely
here onto the n-terminal domain
and the
depleting mutation shown here in red map
onto the c terminal domain
so this really suggested that there is
some
something going on between rpoa
and the camaric acid
so a little bit about
rpoa so rpoa is the alpha subunit of rna
polymerase
it's an essential gene
it is a homodimer
and
it is
really the first step towards the
dimerization of rpoa is really the first
step towards the
assembly of rna polymerase as a whole
the
n-terminal domain
has an interaction with different
transcription factors
and there's also the dimerization
domain in the n-terminal domain
the c-terminal domain also has
interaction with transcription factors
and weak interaction with the dna
so based on the results from the
previous selection experiment it it it
showed us that there's something going
on with rpoa
and so the next library that was built
was a saturation amino acid saturation
library against rpoa and in this library
every amino acid was changed to eat
every other amino acid as well as a stop
codon
and this library generated a pool of
6880
different variants
this library was grown in biological
triplicates
and
it was grown
in minimal media with glucose
and then with ethanol because ethanol
was used to dissolve the cumaric acid
and then at three different
concentrations of camaric acid 0.5 1 and
1.5 makes per ml
these cultures were all
allowed to grow for 48 hours
and then
somewhere as before the genomic dna was
extracted and the
barcodes were pcr'd and then these
amplicons were sent for sequencing
the results from this selection
experiment were
pretty similar to
or they reinforced what we saw in the
first selection experiment
so shown here on the x-axis is the amino
acid position
and then shown here
is the log fold change
of the design um in the
concentration of the cumuric acid over
the control
and shown here are the different
concentrations of chemical acid
here i've outlined the
n-terminal domain the linker
which connects the n-terminal domain in
the c-terminal domain and then the
c-terminal domain
what we see here
in the n-terminal domain is that there
is this little cluster here that's
clearly enriching in the population
and then in the c-terminal domain there
is this cluster here which is depleting
and then also a cluster here which is
enriching
and what you can see
as you
increase the concentration of cameric
acid
is that the
enriching
pockets become more enriching and the
depleting pockets definitely become more
depleting as you go across
so here i'm going to talk a little bit
about where these
clusters of mutations actually
are on the structure of
the rpoa
so there as i said before there are two
clusters of enriching mutations
the
first cluster is at the c-terminal
domain
and this is at the site of interaction
with
transcription factors
the other enriching mutations clusters
at the end terminal domain
and this is at the dimerization site
and then also at a site
distal to the dimerization site which is
at the site of the interaction with
transcription factors
the
depleting mutations cluster um maps onto
the c terminal domain
and is at the site of the transcription
regulatory surface
so based on the results from the
previous selection this really confirmed
to us that there is something going on
with
having an enriching cluster of mutations
and having a depleting cluster
and so the next two libraries that we
built were libraries that were designed
to
engineer even greater sensitivity and
tolerance to the camaric acid
so the way that this was built was that
we started by just looking at
the
enriching
score which is
correlated to how enriching or depleting
the mutation is within the population
and then we plotted that against the
position and then this data was used to
generate these libraries so the way it
worked was that
it was
that there was a scanning um 15 amino
acid edit window
and in every edit window
um the libraries was designed in a way
that there would be three to eight amino
acid mutations in the window
and the chance of a
mutation
appearing in the window
was
equivalent to how enriching it was
in the population or how depleting it
was in the population so if you took the
enrichers library
these mutations here which have the
greatest amount of enrichment you would
expect those to be the most greatly
represented
in the library
and then the opposite for the depleters
library such that these mutations here
which were the
had the most depletion these would be
the most overly represented
within the depleting mutations library
and so once we had these libraries built
we used these for a selection experiment
where we increased the concentration of
cameric acid
so similar as before we took the
libraries and they were all they were
grown in biological triplicate
and then they were grown in mineral
media with glucose and then plus the
addition of dmso
and in the previous selection ethanol
was used as the control however in this
experiment we used dmso because
we used dmso to dissolve the cumuric
acid and this was because we were using
higher concentrations and we saw that
when we used ethanol a bit it was just
too much ethanol for the cells and that
was causing them to not grow so instead
we switched to dmso
and then
we had three different concentrations of
cameric acid one two and three mix per
ml
so then the same as before these
cultures were allowed to grow for two
days
and then the dna was extracted and
the amplicons were sent for sequencing
shown here on the left is the results
from the enriching mutations library
and then shown on the right is the
results from the depleting mutations
library
i again
put in the
sections which correspond to the
n-terminal domain the linker and the
c-terminal domain
shown here on the y-axis we're looking
at the log two-fold change
of the
highest concentration of cameric acid
three megs per ml over the dmso control
and similar as before we definitely see
this these pockets here in the n
terminal domain which are enriching in
the original mutations library
and then there's also this pocket here
that we saw before
which is enriching
in the c terminal domain
and then in both libraries we also saw
enrichment within the linker
section
and in the depleting mutations library
um the results aren't quite as
as
obvious as the enriching mutations
library
but however here in the c terminal
domain you can definitely see that there
is this pocket here
which is showing a lot of depletion
here i'm going to outline the hypotheses
of what we think might actually be going
on
with the cumeric acid and
in these different pockets of mutations
so we think that the enriching mutations
might allow for some sort of an
increased
transcription factor stress response
and this is inferred because the
mutations are in areas that are in the
area that binds to the transcription
factors
it's possible that the depleting
mutations
might be
doing the opposite so hindering the
stress response
by disrupting the transcription factor
binding
and then it's possible that the camaric
acid could be
actually affecting the dimerization site
to prevent the dimerization of rpoa
so similar to
um transcription another
um
necessary cell process is cell division
so
for
the work we did to study the mechanism
of action of was resveratrol
based on the results that we saw we
think that the resveratrol is having
some sort of
disruption to
the cell division cell division
machinery assembly in the cell
there are a couple of different proposed
mechanisms of action of resveratrol and
e coli
one
proposed mechanism of action is that it
could be producing
reactive oxygen species which is causing
damage to the dna
another proposed mechanism of action is
that it could be
suppressing fitzy which is essential for
the formation of the z-ring during cell
division
because there are
a couple of different
hypotheses for what could be going on we
our first library that we wanted to
build um we thought should kind of be a
more general library rather than with
the chemeric acid where we felt built a
gene specific library with this we built
a genome-wide library that was kind of
designed to
target
a lot of different
um
genes specifically transcription factors
and see
what the results of that suggest and
then based on that kind of narrow it
down to what we think could be going on
so with our transcription factor library
we designed it in a way such that we
took every transcription factor
and
in front of it we inserted um two
different we had two different promoter
insertion mutations
um these were both
medium strength promoters inserted at
the minus 16 nucleotide position
and then we also made two knockout
mutations so that a triple stop codon
was inserted at the 10th and 15th amino
acid physicians
we took this transcription factor
library that had these
four different
designs against every transcription
factor
we grew it in biological triplicate
and these triplicates were then grown in
minimal medius glucose dmso which was
used to dissolve the resveratrol
and then
114 micrograms per ml resveratrol and
228 micrograms per ml resveratrol
these cultures were then allowed to grow
for 48 hours and then same as in the
cumeric acid
selection we
took the dna and pcr the barcodes for
the designs
and then we sent these amplicons for
sequencing
so the
results that we saw from this were
that resvertol is having a really large
impact on two specific uh transcription
factors outlined here that we thought
were interesting
the first one is success
and the second one is dica
so sox s is an ros response regulator
specifically
an activator
here we're looking at the log twofold
change
of the design
counts in the 228 micrograms per ml
resveratrol which is the higher
concentration
over the dmso control
and
here we can see
one of the promoter insertion mutations
which is
the most enriched in the population
and then here is the second sox s
promoter insertion
here
we're looking at a similar um
uh representation of the data here we're
looking at the enrichment score
and then the promoter strength across
the x-axis
and we can see that with success as we
increase the promoter strength that
the enrichment score increases
the second
transcription factor that we saw thought
had an interesting result was dica
dica is a cell division regulator
a repressor
and it
it also had a similar
result
with the
increase in promoter strength
so
shown at zero there is very little
enrichment of this design
and then as the
promoter strength is increased
there is a greater enrichment and this
does taper off here for the second
um promoter strength
so dica
represses the operon
containing dic
b which interacts with min c to inhibit
fitzy ring formation
and this second result here this was
what kind of suggested to us that there
could be something going on between
resveratrol and the cell division
machinery
and we used the results from this
library selection to kind of inform the
next library that we'd built
the next library that we built is what
we're calling the morphology and protein
folding library
this library has a knockout
a medium and a high strength promoter
insertion
in front of all genes encoding proteins
in these pathways
and so once we had this library built
the same as before we grew these in
biological triplicates
and they were then grown in mineral
media with glucose
in with the addition of dmso because
that was used to dissolve the
resveratrol
and then
114 and 228 micrograms per mil
resveratrol
these then grew for two days and then
the genomic dna was extracted and the
barcodes were pcr'd and then these
amplicons were sent for sequencing
what we saw in
this selection was that the most
enriching mutations involved changes to
the expression of
different
cell division proteins
so the first
cell division protein that had um a lot
of enrichment was fits a uh fits a
co-localizes with fitzy to the
septal ring structure
fitsell
which is also an essential cell division
protein and it's required for the
localization of fits eye
and lastly tolku
with entolcu is involved in
peptidoglycan processing during cell
division
and it's recruited to the division at
the same time as fits a
here we're looking at the
log twofold change in the design counts
um of the highest concentration of
resveratrol over the dmso control
and here i've outlined in different
colors these um different
mute these different designs changing
the expression of these three different
proteins
shown here
is the
enrichment score on the y-axis again
with the promoter strength on the x-axis
so here for
fits a and fitzell
you can see that there is
very little or no enrichment
with the knockout however as you
increase the promoter strength from the
medium strength promoter up to the high
strength promoter there
is definitely
a drastic increase in enrichment
and then for toku um we actually see the
opposite so there's enrichment um a
decent amount of enrichment in the
toll-q knockout and then as the promoter
strength is increased the enrichment
drastically
drops off in the population
and shown here again is the
order in which these
proteins are
recruited to the cell division machinery
and so based on this data here um we're
not able to
make any definitive claims about how
resveratrol is acting and like what
um its a specific target is in the cell
however this does suggest that
resveratrol is having some sort of
impact on the cell division machinery um
just due to the the fact that changes to
the expression of these three cell
division proteins have
such
drastic changes in enrichment when
they're grown in the present
presence of resveratrol
and finally i just want to make a few
conclusions
about
how we use the onyx genome engineering
platform to study the mechanism of
actions of these small molecules
so the
genome engineering platform enables
the design and the build of the
libraries to be
very simple as well as
very quick so for this work we built a
total of five genome libraries this had
a total
of 23
977 total variants
for each of the genome libraries the
time
the hands-on time actually spent
building them for each of the libraries
would be around an hour if not a little
less
the trackability of the designs in all
of these libraries
allowed
us to have such a high throughput
selection experiment
using the barcode acid
using the barcode diversity assay
we were we were able
to
look at the enriching and depleting
designs in the population and
make and
analyze the distribution of these
designs
and then finally the onyx workflow
really is ideal for studying the
mechanism of small molecules because it
allowed us to
identify
for cumeric acid
a
specific function
functional region of a single protein
rpoa which is being affected by the
cumeric acid
and then for resveratrol
it allowed us to
identify a
specific functional class of protein
which is being disrupted by the
resveratrol
and with that i would like to thank you
for your time for listening
for today's to today's webinar and i'd
be happy to take any questions now
thank you aaliyah for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click in the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
why did you decide to study chomeric
acid and resveratrol
so we decided to study these two small
molecules
for a couple of different reasons the
first is that these are really
interesting small molecules um due to
the different properties that i
outlined in the presentation
such as the fact that they have
anti-inflammatory properties
and then another reason is that they
represent two use cases for the onyx for
studying
small molecules so with cumuric acid we
had prior data to go off of to have some
sort of a lead to design a more targeted
genome library
whereas for resveratrol
we didn't really have a whole lot to go
off of and so because of that we
designed a more
broad
genome-wide library targeting all of the
different transcription factors
and these also served as really good
controls for one another because
resveratrol is derived from temeric acid
great thank you
next question
are there plans to build more targeted
libraries to study the mechanism of
action of resveratrol
yes so for the next library that we're
planning to build to study the mechanism
of action for resveratrol
we're going to build
different saturation mutagenesis
libraries targeting
the
proteins identified as enrichers and
depleters in that selection experiment
so that would be the fits a
fifth l toll queue and
dica
and then once we have that library built
we'll be using that in a subsequent
resveratrol resveratrol selection
experiment
thank you
next question
did you test the impact of camaric acid
and resveratrol on other genes
yes so we studied um
what was going on with camaric acid we
used that in a selection experiment
with another saturation mutagenesis
library designed against an essential
gene
um specifically fitzy and we did this
just to see
if there would be a similar response as
what we saw with the
rpoa saturation mutagenesis library and
we did not see any sort of
clustering of enriching
and depleting regions
and then we also studied resveratrol
um against
um
we also studied resveratrol against the
rpoa
saturation mutagenesis library to see if
that would also have the same effect and
we did not see any of the clustering
enriching or depleting regions
okay
next question
maybe i missed hearing this but can this
onyx system also be applied to yeast and
fungi
yes so you can use the onyx genome
engineering platform to
design libraries in yeast specifically
s cerevisiae and in yeast you can have
between 100 and 6 000
different unique variants in a library
all right thank you
next question
great presentation
why does resveratrol being derived from
chumeric acid results in it serving as a
good control also would you recommend
the onyx system for studies of larger
molecules
so this
so you're able to we were thinking that
you're able to use the cameric acid
and resveratrols as
controls for one another um just because
they are of like a similar size
and um relatively like similar chemical
composition and so
our thinking was that if we used one
for the other and saw the same effect
that that
might suggest that the
the result that we're seeing isn't
actually due to the interaction between
the cameric acid
and the rpoa
and so we just did that kind of as a
control for that
all right
next question how are bar codes added
and analyzed and are they integrated
into the chromosome
so the barcodes are not
integrated into the genome they are on a
plasmid
and each of the barcodes is associated
with a
unique design in your library and so
after you
have your pool of edited cells
you're able to pcr amplify across the
barcode and then
submit that
that amplicon for sequencing and then
using our
resolver software you're able to analyze
the distribution of each of those
barcodes
in relation to the entire pool of edited
cells
all right thank you
next question
have you been able to translate
conclusions about the mode of action to
successful biosynthesis of these
molecules in microbes
so we haven't taken it as far as to
kind of like relate
the
the results that we saw here to
the actual biosynthesis of
these two small molecules however i i do
think that that would be
very interesting to see if there
would be a correlation between
these these enriching mutations that we
saw and having
improved
successful biosynthesis of the small
molecule
all right thank you
next question would it be possible to
study a complex system such as probiotic
fermentates
i think that that
would be possible
to study just given
the wide range of different
genome libraries that you'd be
able to study
or build i mean so you'd be able to
make a lot of different genome-wide
targets
you'd also i'm just thinking if you have
like a specific
fermentation pathway that you could also
make
different promoter insertions or
changes to different expression
conditions of each of those genes
encoding those things in your pathway
and i think that that could definitely
be a
a good use case for these libraries
all right thank you
next question
what organisms does onyx support
so the onyx supports
e coli and yeast specifically s
cerebesia
all right
and we will wrap up with that quest that
last question
thank you again aaliyah for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor in scripta for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
you